i must give the british people a very
simple
instruction you must stay at home
[Music]
you should not be meeting friends if
your friends ask you
to meet you should say no
i know the damage that this disruption
is doing
and will do to people's lives to their
businesses
and to their jobs
[Music]
the way ahead is hard and it is still
true
that many lives will be lost
what's going on behind the mask
to mark world mental health day we
assess the mental impact
of a global crisis am i feeling angry
grumpy lonely or just sad
to be honest i think i'm feeling all of
them at the same time
camilla kept a diary for us during
lockdown
forced to shield due to a heart problem
soon her biggest enemy
was not the virus but loneliness i'm a
little disappointed with some people
some friends that i've not heard from
anywhere near as much as i expected to
the feeling i've
have now or have had more over in the
last six months
is just of being very numb to everything
um feeling like i can't i can't
get a reaction out of myself for
anything
even watching movies or tv that i would
normally enjoy
it's just oh you know everything just
feels a bit bland everything's a bit
switched off
there's a difference between isolation
and being socially isolated and lonely
isolation people can live with and a lot
of people ride it
quite well feeling lonely can be a very
damaging feeling in fact
loneliness is a killer and what about
physical contact
i've had none i i in june i bought a
shower curtain and i hugged my mum
whilst i was wearing it and that's
all i've had that's the only hug i've
had um
since february the virus hasn't just
increased loneliness
but also anxiety and uncertainty
musician astrid says the loss of her job
has left her struggling
as debt
it increases right you start looking at
yourself
and your self-worth i came here to work
and to study and to you know
live out my potential and that is being
taken away from me
so yes you do feel powerless and
sometimes you think what's the point
a recent national study found the rate
of depression has doubled on last year
another that mental distress on a level
requiring treatment
also rose sharply during lockdown and
remains high
it's been like a sort of pebble dropping
into the pond with with ripples that go
right out i think at the at the
beginning of the crisis it was
a real direct impact on fear of the the
virus itself but as we've
gone on there's the sort of more sort of
indirect effects
on people's jobs and livelihoods and
also their sort of social structures
yet despite the growing need for help
sky news has found the number of
referrals to adult nhs mental health
services
fell in the five months from march there
were over
200 000 fewer referrals than the year
before
there seemed from the statistics to be
fewer people being referred
into the nhs for help i mean that is
definitely a worry and we're very very
clear as the government that
the nhs and all its mental health
services
are absolutely open for business and
people
should be taking advantage of that but
charities fear
we're storing up trouble we've had
services that have been absolutely
threadbare before covet and now
people feel that they can't receive help
people have relied on being monitored
with telephone calls
often they just wait and wait and the
call never comes
it is a troubling new reality isn't it
the things that bind us parties
gatherings
they've become illegal but the things we
strive for
our ambitions our jobs relationships
they've become
more difficult and it's getting us down
i was talking to my therapist earlier
this week
studies show the mental health risk has
increased most for younger people
recovering alcoholic ben robinson says
he's coped with lockdown
but it's the uncertainty of the future
that's impacting his peer group
no one can stand here and say it hasn't
made an impact on their lives but
especially for those of my generation
that are looking to make the next move
in their life which let's be honest
under 30 you're always looking for that
next move
it's not there and even people that
aren't in my circles but my friends who
don't have specific mental health
problems have started to highlight them
to me
almost coming to me for advice on how do
i deal with this low-lying feeling of
you know lack of motivation or lack of
worth
another group more severely mentally
affected by the pandemic
are those from poorer backgrounds at the
church of the resurrection in ely
cardiff
the pandemic has been intensely
challenging since lockdown started we've
done
10 suicide funerals which is way above
our
annual average for suicides
and of course when the furlough scheme
ends who knows what's going to happen
with that picture
i would say they all had underlying
mental health issues that might have
been just
slightly in the distance normally and
manageable
but with the pandemic losing their jobs
or a relationship breaking up
then that's been the thing that's tipped
them over the edge the older members of
the congregation
are also feeling the effects of
loneliness one of the things that i
found it was
was sleeping um
i could usually go to sleep but then i'd
wake up early hours in the morning and
of course in the you know when it's
quiet all these things go through your
mind
and i i still have that i still do wake
up
you just long for somebody to come and
knock your door and come in
the one thing i would want to say is
that it's something that each
one of your viewers every single person
in the country can do something about
we can pick up the phone and talk to
someone we can write a letter
and tell someone how much they mean to
us in stansted villages have gone one
step further
launching a mental health outreach
project elaine nibbs acted
after being shocked by three suicides in
the village
the response was so great when we put
the appeal out yeah what i didn't expect
was so many people coming to us
and chatting we had a stall like this
and people were approaching us
asking what we were doing and then
telling us
things like the life stories and
troubles i was going through and traumas
had had
we had quite a few people crying people
are coming to us are saying they didn't
know they could talk to people there's
no one they could talk to
on here we've got the details of our
facebook
group the volunteers steer people
towards services
and offer a much needed listening ear
it's really really lovely like knowing
that you can go
and speak to people like that yeah and
you can go to groups
it's really nice if you're in a bad
place yeah
have you found the lockdown and the
pandemic quite difficult
um yes
gemma is getting the help she needs but
mental health services are strained
and 2020 has put more of us on edge
struggling with something lethal and
sometimes feeling
no one has noticed jason farrell sky
news